as we look at this I want to point out i
wait i went to deal with it in full
detail like i lured this question but we
had similar issues which we these two
questions right because essentially it's
understanding the nature of what does
this mean right what does this mean and
therefore how many solutions are there
for me probably because I've been
dealing with these questions so long you
start to get a bit of a center oh this
should have lots of solutions or they
should have not so many solutions okay
now in this case one of the reasons why
you should know this should have a what
the purpose solutions is think about
this okay number one the powers are high
the powers on ice right like you've got
a tan squared in there and that's not
the only thing that's going on you guys
know if for instance I gave you
something like x squared you know
exactly how many solutions there will be
for this if I start to add in terms with
successively higher powers I'm just
making this up no I'll make it mind you
know one of the things we looked at in
polynomials in extension one is oh okay
what powers for solutions okay um some
of them might not be real but they're
there nonetheless okay now when you have
a look at this essentially what these
things are good nu square you make a
function more extreme right so you know
when you go from here to here you've got
lots of steeper part ok so it's also
waving up and down more and more times
okay so therefore this is going to have
lots of solutions just by betting that
secondly you've got these guys also
coming into play right the more you have
of those the more complex your solution
is ours rather than more complex your
quadrant is rather more complicated your
credit card is the most solutions are
likely to have problem so here's the way
I went through it step number one or
should I say era number one is to get
everything on one
do not divide through do not do not do
not divide here's my first line now we
know kind of intuitively all right on
simpler equations something like this
for instance okay on simpler occasions
like that we know not to divide through
right dividing through by X causes you
put some problems because will you do
that what happens you lose a solution
because what you've done is you've
turned a quadratic into a linear
function and of course you're going to
go from two solutions to one and exactly
the same thing will happen here except
the effect is compounded because it's a
periodic functions if you divide through
by side tuna in fact I think you lose
three solution okay so I've moved
everything on one side and now instead
of dividing through I should factorize
right star take out so beat up right
there you go so there's the first part
and then what gets left behind good ok
now you factorize that if you wanted I
suppose you could take this time here
and you could actually factorize that
and other steps if you want to do um you
don't have to that I think far more
standard slightly more concise is to at
this point for edge off yeah to say okay
well I factorize enough for me right I'm
gonna have sine theta equals 0 or I'm
gonna have Ted squared 10 squares what
value could that take it takes a third
but of course this guy here we did too
we had two common errors here number one
just like before we ignore one of the
solutions so we might have said I it's
cool i'll just take the square root
right now this will give you a pair of
solutions but of course you're missing
the plus or minus now the second error
was even for some of us who put the plus
or minus their richest ish toward the
fact of the minus of their descent i
woulda just have two solutions okay if
you're going to have them in some ways
this is kind of an easier problem to
sold that if there was just the one over
three because if you've got plus or
minus that is your solution to every
single quadrant right put your one two
three four you're going to get a
solution every single time okay so
therefore let's come over here ok so our
solutions are zero hi 2 pi now just a
quick note again a less common air up
but an error that some has made
nonetheless was to figure out that there
were three solutions it is not too I was
so used to there being two solutions to
our tree versions for dr. dupuy I'm
going to keep on reminding you right
especially at our level as extension one
student this is a graph this is a graph
when's it equal to zero and you guys
know exactly what the graph looks like
okay there are four students who are
kind of struggling and kind about that
level of tia where it's like I just
barely wrap my head around how to look
at something like this at how to
generate solutions okay going towards a
graph is a bit much for them and it's
just extra stuff to having your head and
be confusing but not for you guys right
this should be something that's right at
the tip of your like on the front of
your mind look at this as you look at
this you should see one two three and if
you're not there seeing that year that's
okay like that's the reason why we do
these assessments to learn that but you
need to start moving towards there maybe
you just want to spend some time before
we get these questions just looking at
graphs just do a lot more graphic so
those sort of suck into your mighty like
okay like you get this point where a
picture pops into your mind okay like
when I say the word dog it's hard for
you to not picture a dog in your mind
right and now you're like oh I have a
picture but all you might have no 10
he's getting with it in the same way i
want you have a picture in your mind
when that cuts off okay um question
I canceled the song paid off yeah I said
yes oh yeah okay sure all right so yes
if this was doing if you did this right
so this is dividing through by Cynthia
what you really have to say here is all
but what that means is sine theta can't
be 0 because of course otherwise if you
will do this you'd be divided by 0 which
you cannot do okay but of course doing
this is exactly what happens in T
results like where you introduce t
results you remove a solution because
cos theta appears on the denominator
right so in other words you've
eliminated by the work if you don't so
therefore down the end once you start
where you get to this line right there
you say oh no but wait right back in the
beginning I did this but there's no
reason inherent in the question why that
should be so so I'd better check okay
but of course what you've done amounts
to this except without taking away
solutions that you weren't supposed to
take away in the first place so there's
no reason why you would go about this I
think it's kind of like oh it's like
it's like having like a painting and
they rip you off half of the Patriots I
don't need to worry about that and it's
an odd way come back I didn't mean what
I said and then putting it back in
attaching it together I think it's much
it's a it's a straight line just to do
it this way okay and also just remember
exam conditions if I did this like most
of you guys should make this error I
would just forget about it and I
wouldn't come back and test it i think
you acquired me and it's great that you
did that removable again so that's why i
don't recommend what's the old base
angle what's the acute angle that's the
first solution saves pilot seats right
so if you've got pilot six and that's
your first solution your obtuse one that
some correspondent will be five pi 06
your first reflecting on a seven
season and 11 5 6 is what you get go
back into play